[Music]
the entire north is threatened
by the english king
[Music]
then i want to see if this fight is mine
i heard sam that you looked out your
window today and saw yourself on a
billboard for this series yeah i mean i
don't often you know rely on outside
things for gratification but to see that
was quite overwhelming
to my family
when you get the role like you audition
for it obviously this is a question for
both of you you get the role
did you begin to research because both
of your characters are legendary i mean
how do you sort of go into it did you do
a lot of research and how do you get
into that viking spirit at that point
yeah i certainly
dove into some some of the history and i
think that's one of the joys of doing a
historical
role is that you you learn a bit about a
period that you otherwise wouldn't learn
about and so yeah i read up on the kings
and king canutes invasion and realized
that
that history and the changing of power
was was
an incredible story
um but one of the nice things that for
my portrayal of harold this is sort of
an origin story in many respects and we
know about harold hardrada in the later
stages of his life
here we got to play with the idea of his
youth and play with a concept that maybe
he had a best friend in this strange
greenlander who arrived and would become
lath eric's in the man to discover
america to myself i remember exactly
where i was sitting in history class
when i was learning about leif erikson
and eric the red i think it was like one
of the only exams i got an a in actually
um
and uh yeah so research started pretty
early but i dived certainly into a lot
of the sagas and a lot of the history
and i was also always fascinated with
the mythology in the pagan world
but uh for me it was important to strip
back and tell a very human story about a
man trying to find his way in the world
and you know
simply looking after the people he loves
did i read that you used to watch the
original viking series with your dad
what can original og fans expect from
this series how will it set itself apart
and or what is in there for vikings fans
the ogeers
the ogs yeah no i'm an og i i really
enjoyed the original series and i think
they can certainly expect a lot of
action and we certainly kick it into
gear i mean michael hurst was an amazing
showrunner of the original series we now
have jeb stewart who
you know wrote die hard and the fugitive
and so we kind of welcome a new yeah
absolutely bow down to him um we welcome
a bit of a gear shift in the action
realm and um
we
as leo says that there are certainly
echoes of the names and the greats that
lived before us and so i guess we hope
to continue and honor the legacy that
has been laid down before us
and for you leo um
i want to ask who in the cast got most
into the fighting scenes i know you you
learned a lot about combat in that who
is the best at it like who really took
it to a level like the next level
and then also you have i told you
they're gonna come kill me i can't i
can't tell you that it's a closely
guarded secret i won't tell anybody no
no no no i don't believe you
i do i actually think like frida frieda
really got into it and like i remember
her telling like she'd be doing roles in
her bedroom like trying to practice for
it and louisa as well in that first
battle
she unleashed
primal energy that you could you could
feel but i think yeah i think the point
is that everybody once they once they
get on those battlefields and you're
given the tools by our stunt team
of what the steps are going to look look
like but once you're there on the
battlefield and the adrenaline kicks in
everyone just goes full pelt one last
question for you leo you balance the
fighting with the love scenes what's
more choreographed the love scenes or
the fighting scenes
he's the lover and a fighter
what's more choreographed i think um
yeah the fights are more choreographed
because if you if you get the fights
wrong then you're gonna have an axe in
your head or something but no doing
those doing those scenes with frida was
really nice because
yeah harold's a berserker and a warrior
and a speech giver but those intimate
vulnerable moments that he shares with
freydis
the kind of variety that you really look
for as an actor in the role
you're a long way from home ladies
i am on a mission
to learn my destiny
train her
[Music]
let's go again
you're both amazing
in this series amazing one thing that i
found fascinating to learn
about the viking society is they were
very
more than maybe other societies at the
time egalitarian where women could own
land they could have autonomy over their
marriages for each of you how did it
inform your character i'll start with
you caroline
well you're right about that and being
scandinavian both freda and i are born
in stockholm is part of our heritage our
history you know we know a lot about
viking history and the female aspect of
that
so that was very sort of appealing to
the characters because like a thousand
years ago we can relate to what it was
like to be a woman and then you know
stuff happened which wasn't that easy
being a woman so to be in that sort of
scenery together with freda and form the
characters they have a goal they have a
mission together and it's not about sort
of a husband or children or whatever
it's about a goal it's about a belief
together that has been an amazing
journey and i'm so so proud to be a part
of that
yeah and for you freda i mean
physically
watching you do those fight scenes
i mean
you just gave yourself over to it you
were incredible a lot of your co-stars
today are saying you were the best
fighter of anybody you took it the most
seriously you got into wow
that's very kind of them to say no but i
think for me the understanding freitas
it was a very
physical aspect you know she grew up in
a very harsh reality she comes from a
very remote place where she's ever since
she was little had to hunt for her own
food it's been a struggle she is a
fighter she's a survivor
and i think what maybe sets freitas
apart from everyone else is
you know men maybe are you know they're
trained to fight freitas isn't she's not
a trained fighter she's not like harold
who had a squire since he was a child
he's a prince you know learning how to
fight like like a little boy for freight
is maybe because she is a victim and
she's a survivor of this horrific you
know sexual
assault she you know she comes you know
she fights with her heart and that's
what i loved about playing this
character that maybe it's not the most
technical maybe she's not the most
elegant or the most skillful but if life
knocks her into teeth she's going to
just spit the teeth out and stand up and
go come again what what else can you
throw at me
and
i i love that i think it's so important
that we get to see that on screen so
i'm really really excited for that
journey for fans of the original series
what kind of epic action can they expect
from this series and also just
personally what kind of training went in
like what was your i know you had axe
training what was your sort of favorite
aspect of it all what do you think
you're the best at at this point well i
i think for me um what i was really
thankful that now you know towards the
end we can pick up any weapon and fight
with it we started with my little knife
and you know fighting with you know i've
killed people with anything like with my
bracelet
and uh not a lot of people can say that
they strangled a six foot seven man with
this bracelet but hey i can't
you absolutely can and caroline for you
your character um
he rules in a different way i think of
all the characters she sort of has the
most calm demeanor but she has a power
like you do not want to mess with her
she becomes a mentor figure to freitas
can you sort of talk about how you went
about differentiating yourself from the
other characters in the series well
being like a fierce strong leader as yao
hokan i figured like she's seen it all
she's not a young woman she's she's
traveled she's rated she's conquered
stuff she speaks passionately about her
young days when she used to etc so i
figured this woman is
she's seen it all you know and she's so
calm cool and collected within her power
and a woman like that you don't have to
raise your voice because you have the
power when you walk into that you have
the power you know what you're doing
plus i think the one of the core main
things of her she's not afraid of she's
not afraid to die she's not afraid of
death
and that's how i try to portray the
character she's not scared i mean she's
so headstrong also in her in her beliefs
so she knows she's going to valhalla but
if you play a character who's not afraid
to die you kind of scrape up all those
and you have like rich you have like
that strongness that's what's you know
that's what you see
you are here because
you
are
[Music]
my first question for you both
is obviously you're playing real life
historical figures how deep a dive do
you go into
when you're preparing for the role well
yeah you have to do a certain amount uh
you know when you're
lucky enough to uh to to um
to play a historical character like this
there's obviously a lot of research
that's out there
uh already done for you uh to a certain
extent all you have to do is pick up a
book and and take it in so it's a
pleasure to do it really you know uh
they're interesting characters in their
own rights and that's why uh
there was a show beforehand called
vikings and why and that's why there's
there's now a vikings valhalla these
guys are
uh interesting and uh worthwhile
i feel like with king canoe
he's very complex i don't know whether
to like him or not but with olaf i feel
like it's what you see is what you get
you know exactly who he is do you think
that is fair and how was it building
that relationship between the two of you
because eventually we know that the two
of you
are very much at odds i think um
knuts um
pretty multi-layered uh in his approach
uh he likes to show different faces to
different people
whereas i think with uh olaf um kind of
what you see is what you get he's he's
pretty hardcore do you concur
johannes well what she sees what you get
to an extent then there's there are
twists and turns there which is is quite
nice and
as to as to building the relationship
between canute and olaf and different
characters
uh and relating to what you're asking
about uh the historical aspect of it
on the day you always have to be
careful to to focus on the on the see
the scene that you're doing and not be
clouded with too much information
like in in my case the the character is
he becomes a saint in the catholic
church after his death but that doesn't
really help me
act out a scene
you know how does that information help
me play a scene it really doesn't but it
is it is nice to sort of
familiarize yourself with the history of
the characters and it does help each
extent
but on the day you are have to be
focused on the on the scene that you're
you're doing let's talk about on the day
like the london bridge scene
it was so intense for people who are
original vikings fans of the original
series i mean i think this is just you
know the pacing is different jeb has
talked about building a completely
different world but for you as an actor
when you're on set and you're filming a
scene like that can you talk about like
the adrenaline rush how much training
goes into it how well do you sleep that
night when you go to bed does it just is
it very cathartic for you as an actor uh
well
no i would say seeing it put together is
cathartic because on the day it's it's
stretched over two and a half weeks it's
four different locations i'm on a boat
in that sequence and i don't see any
bridge i've never seen the bridge with
my own eyes and the bridge doesn't exist
it's in four different pieces
and uh so for us we're just going
through each little setup that has been
laid out and planned
and you go through the motions and then
when you see the assembly that's when
you go wow they really they did it and
you know i'm in there but they did it
yeah no it's pretty incredible i mean
who who of the cast members i'm asking
kind of everybody in the cast today who
of the cast members
fully immerse themselves into the fight
training the most would you say
frieda gustafsson of sweden hands down
without fail
really i mean that's been the consensus
so far
has it well that's what surprised me
you know she's she's the boss lady she
would bring everyone to shame with her
amazing work ethic she she's amazing
she's my favorite by far i'm sorry
bradley but she is
i agree
[Music]
vikings are preparing for an invasion
what do you intend to do
fight i was very excited to talk to you
because you're i'm not one of my
favorite characters because he's very
crafty
well we try you know we've got to keep
people guessing you've got to have long
long-term plans of survival in this
world of vikings otherwise might go for
bid well that's my whole first question
for you i mean he's a shrewd political
player what do you think his number one
role is for surviving in that world uh
patience i would not have thought you
were going to say that yeah but that's
how he gets away with it he thinks about
stuff he doesn't act accordingly he
doesn't go there's an axe i'm gonna chop
that guy in the face i've been
explaining this to other people it's
sort of like chess like if season one is
him setting up all the pieces on the
board then season two he makes one move
and then season three we'll see what
happens next and that's the way that
wins but your character he really does
play more with his mind than with his
physical brute strength like a lot of
you know the characters on this on this
show
um how delicious for you as an actor is
it to sort of play the duplicity of a
character it's it's really good fun i
mean that's the truth of it it's knowing
that you have an arc that will sustain
it as well it's knowing that
you can
not mislead the audience but not feel
like you have to push them in a certain
direction at any one time um you can be
slow like the patients that i say
goldman have as an actor you know you
can trust in the story right so you can
trust in jeb to know that as this thing
unravels everyone ago
did you ever surprise yourself on set
with you with something that sort of
occurred that you didn't expect the
things i've always liked sort of
sneaking in and some of them have made
the edit is him being lighter and a bit
cheekier than people might expect like i
think he's got a devilish sense of humor
i think you'd have to to survive under
all those courts um
there's one particular beast in episode
7 which i think is my single greatest
work today and i'm still stunned that
they left that in the edit
what moment
um it's when i'm talking to forkbeard um
and it looks like uh
everything might be off for for godwin
but there's just a short little moment
he almost turns to the camera and just
sighs but it's it's a it's a funky it's
a blink and you miss it but i'm really
proud of it it's ridiculous i'm going to
go back and re-watch it
you almost broke the broke the fourth
wall so in that sense then how does he
really feel about dealing with a child
king
i think he is prepared to give a child
king the same opportunity that he's
prepared to give a viking king he's
prepared to let them
make their first moves and to see if
they are worthy of the weight and
unfortunately quite a lot of people in
this universe aren't necessarily as
strong confident and good as leading as
they think they are you've been known to
play in a you know a period
drama or two between the white queen and
other projects you've been involved in
but why was this
just a few so you're used to the card
but how do you think the viking world
differs from those types of um from the
other shows that you've worked on and
why was this role perfect for you as an
actor
i think i've i've i'm a boy so i've
always loved vikings i think there's
something cool about that so that
appealed to me in the first place so the
idea of long ships and big shields and
all of that that's that's a that's a
tick um
when you then realize that it's written
by jeb stewart who wrote die hard and
the fugitive then that's that's the
second pretty massive tick and if you
haven't said yes by then then you're an
idiot but the third tip comes along when
you realize that you're basically
playing the hans gruber allen written
part of the series and you go
yeah i'd be an absolute [ __ ] not to do
this so
it's it's that thing yes i've been in a
lot of period drums and that's because i
love doing it um
but in this instance
it's there's there's a wink to godwin
all the way through this and a really
interesting character arc
which is based in history of a character
that i don't think many people will have
heard of and
and that's all to his absolute triumph
as a survivor
it is our blood
it is viking vlog
my first question for you is being that
you're the writer of die hard in the
fugitive
a feature film action writer how do you
when you're doing many many episodes and
you managed to do it keep that pace of
like an action film because it really
doesn't let up and how do you determine
how you're gonna pace you know a grand
series like this well it was this was a
really fun series to think about like
that and it's so funny you should
mention that but pace was one of the
things that we talked about
from the beginning it's like how do we
how do we do this how do we tell the
story with the camera
instead of having two people sit there
in a room and saying you know i love
those flowers that's great you need to
pick up the flowers and we kind of go
it's it's really terrific to to have
filmmakers who
up one appreciate that and two have the
skills to actually do that and so um the
short answer is lots and lots and lots
of planning i mean that's all i can tell
you lots of planning so that we can get
it all in
speaking of the planning i mean i'm just
thinking about like the london bridge
scene quick question for you london
bridge is falling down does that come
from this moment like the viking it does
i mean you know there are many different
variations of it but pretty much most
people will tell you that that nursery
rhyme came from the vikings tearing it
down who knew when you were a kid
singing that's right you knew i didn't
know i didn't know until i got into the
research
so speaking of research something like i
think your crew had to build six bridges
five or six bridges to actually film the
one london bridge falling down how
satisfying was it to demolish it or was
it sort of devastating was it was really
it was actually very sad i went out um
to watch two of them go under the
under the bulldozer but it was um and i
kept thinking maybe we are going to need
this again
so uh but it you know you need a certain
part of a bridge for a certain aspect
for a certain shot
and and like i said we've you know tom
conroy our production designer is just
fabulous and and you know so
each of those pieces had different parts
that we had to shoot and uh and
you know when you see it all put
together it it's it's just magic
it's a pretty spectacular scene there's
a lot of spectacular scenes i mean
there's the initial scene where they're
coming across on the boat practically
speaking how challenging was that how
practical was it and how much cg was
involved well we did shoot that on a
tank but i have to tell you it was a lot
of water a lot of cold it was ireland as
you can you can tell um you know the
the cast were fantastic
you know as they
probably told you that it's it was cold
it's stamp it's really wet and they did
it again
and again and again and again and again
and uh we had that boat on gimbal so
that they're really you know they're
really riding some incredible
um you know vertical and then being
dropped down so it was it was a fun fun
to watch when you're dry and standing on
the sidelines amazing i know you're
working on
finalizing some of the scenes and and
episodes i haven't seen i've seen the
first eight but amongst our crew at
rotten tomatoes a lot of us were asking
like are we gonna see eric the red are
we gonna see william the conqueror what
are your plans what can you tease
well i can tease all of that but i i
can't tell you much detail about it
right at this particular point but i i
did one of the things that drove me
about the the life and the the freitas
character was uh and you see it a lot in
in season one is where did they come
from and the answer to that is eric the
red
and you know you see that part of life
who he's trying to push it away push it
away that sort of dark underbelly that
his father has and that he sees in his
sister so accurately
so um so uh yeah there's a there's some
really great stuff out there over the
horizon i know you've you've talked
about the original vikings series i'm
curious if michael hurst has seen your
first eight episodes if he's seen it his
reaction to it and you said that it's
like almost like apples and oranges
they're two totally different series so
can you explain how they're different
look i was a fan of michael's series so
i wanted as a fan i really wanted to to
not disappoint that group of people like
myself at the same time i really
you know i wanted i wanted an audience
that did that didn't know vikings that
didn't know a viking from a saxon to be
able to just fit right into the story
and go without having to see all those
other episodes that was really important
to me because i think that the some of
the stories that we're telling
um were very different from the stories
that were in the original uh so it's a
dance that i had to do but um look my
wife produces broadway musicals and she
loves the story she's not a viking you
know
but she's caught in because the stories
i think are compelling and they're
relevant to what's going on right now so
that's a good litmus test for you know
for me nikki if that if that works i
know i know it'll work for other people
you